[Musique]
la recherche scientifique mère du
progrès coûte cher très cher aujourd'hui
elle est en péril le gouvernement ne la
subventionnent pas assez vos dons sont
inexistants et sans argent elles
risquent de pourrir et avec elle
l'espoir d'un avenir meilleur pour
éviter ce naufrage depuis quelques temps
les grands patrons de la science et de
la médecine ont pris les choses en main
à tongon travail est trop bon fois
l'accélérateur de particules est un jeu
pythie sur la face à l'eire
mais avec quoi on attaquait tout ce qui
nous reste est dans les deux micros
lazers do we too
et aux professeurs coop et au docteur
livio de descendre
[Musique]
on parla germain madeleine et patrons la
madeleine on est déjà passé hier les
gens qui parlent trop
[Musique]
on n'est pas mardi
c'est tout c'est pas travaillé cette
nuit j'étais de garde à l'hôpital ça
allait bien je castelli
[Musique]
et là c'est la gencive le matin et pour
l' analyse d'urines professeur caldera
mais qu'est ce qui se passe j'espère que
vous n'êtes pas malade n'était plus toi
tonnes n'ont pas tous les jours a pitié
pas tous les jours
nous reviendrons la question n'est plus
rien castelli tu sais qu'une pharmacie
sa flamme plus vite qu'une omelette
norvégienne
[Musique]
personne ne bouge
c'est pour la recherche
on n'avait jamais vu un qui se passe
vient juste de partir
[Musique]
joe longo l'institut pasteur
selon un accord tacite la bande de
l'institut pasteur écumé la rive gauche
et celle du cnrs se réservait la rive
droite
cette violation de frontière que
venaient de perpétrer jo longo directeur
de l'institut pasteur
allait-elle rallumer la guerre des gros
bonnets de la recherche afin d'éviter le
pire le professeur vanony de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé se
propose comme médiateur et organise un
dîner en terrain neutre
l'île de la cité dans un restaurant où
toute la médecine de pointe se
retrouvent le soir
bien du plaisir dans le jeu
j'aime le jeu
le creusot
c'est nous
jours
[Musique]
pour le g
et je retire mes bleus
nous
j'étais jo longo était arrivé le premier
au rendez vous
[Musique]
tony soit le bienvenu
joey la d'jo tony je suis contente de
voir
depuis le temps
la dernière fois c'était quand aux
entretiens de bichat
c'est ça oui je me souviens tu avais
parlé merveilleusement des allergies
l'intestin grêle
trois ans déjà mes amis
qu'est-ce que tu es venu faire dans mon
secteur joue ton secteur
tu veux parler de l'infra cellulaire je
parlais de la ponte du commerce et de
l'industrie
rive droite il ya vingt ans je t'en ai
fait rayer de l'ordre aujourd'hui je te
donne une chance comme celle que tu
donnes à des rats de laboratoire
tony hale comment tu trouves la
chanteuse c'est une généticienne les
depuis quatre ans chez moi elle a du
talent non je veux le freak show j'ai
besoin d'un accélérateur de particules
vite très vite sinon des américains vont
te plaît tu as peur pourtant nobel eisa
attrait pour le nobel pendant le
génocide ah non si à tous les étages ils
viennent de partout
je suis leur dernière recours caldera et
tu sais ce que j'ai pour les soigner
mois un bout de coton et de l'alcool à
90 j'ai même pas de quoi m'acheter un
scalaire mois tony ya plus un rond sur
la rive gauche
laisse-moi com - quartier de l'opéra
jamais le fric jamais alors c'est la
guerre
ainsi sachez le chaque année des
centaines d'hommes et de femmes meurent
dans l'ombre que des milliers d'autres
puissent vivre grâce à la rochelle une
idée est d aider la recherche
envoyez vos dons au ccp 12 227 k/w 293
vivement sera obligée d'intervenir site
[Musique]